i would recommend looking back through
john meadows's content i think his one
weird tricks that he threw out did have
a very excellent signal to noise ratio
he'd be like yeah just like
try this this weird uh series of
exercises or like particular exercise
for your lats like i promise it's going
to blow them up and i'd be like
john that looks
no but then i try it i'd be like
goddammit john you're a genius
so anyway i i cribbed this in part from
him um
because you know
he
he's spent a lot of his time
kind of in the public eye of the fitness
industry uh in his in his 40s and later
um you know so his his joints weren't as
young as they previously had been but
one of the hallmarks of of his training
approach like if you'd watch a lot of
his training videos is he would train
heavy and he would train really hard
and so one of the things he was trying
to accomplish is like how can i do that
while keeping my joints as happy with me
as as they can be um and so the strategy
he came up with which is
very simple uh but in my experience
works really well
is whatever
whatever joint you're about to train the
muscles around
um that generally doesn't like you
just start with a
i don't know the best wording for this
but just kind of like a non-stressful
pump type exercise so
it's not something that's going to take
you through
any sort of like extreme stretch it's
not going to take
you know any of your tissues close to
their tensile limits
and you're just going to do high reps
with it and importantly i don't know why
this matters but it seems to matter you
want to do it for both sides of the
joint so for example if you were going
to do some some triceps training you'd
want to do something for your triceps
but also your biceps just to kind of
warm up everything around your elbow
joint and when i say kind of like a
non-stressful type lift uh you wouldn't
want to do skull crushers where you're
you know taking your elbows into full
flexion under heavy load um you know
nothing like that so you know it might
be something like rope push downs um
and you know you're just going to start
with
a couple sets or even just one set of 20
30 reps relatively close to failure of a
triceps exercise
repeat the process with a biceps
exercise and then from there you can
start moving into heavier stuff so you
know that's when you might want to get
into your skull crushers for sets of 8
to 12 or you know really any other
triceps exercise
and
don't know why this works but it works
quite well
you know your tendons seem to be happier
your joints seem to be happier
and
one other additional little wrinkle that
i would add to this
is so step one do kind of high rep pump
type work
across both sides of the joint
step two just kind of train normally
after that and then step three i think
uh at least i personally experience
dividends from ending my training with
kind of what i would call like a
stretchy type movement um
so you know you you are now looking for
something that is going to take that
joint through a full range of motion
uh and you're generally going to do like
paused reps where you can really kind of
let your muscles like sink into it like
feel a good stretch in the muscle um
and do that to end with so
uh let's see an example of how this
could work is let's say you have creaky
knees so you're gonna start your
like knee dominant lower body training
um maybe with just some light knee
extensions and then very important don't
forget uh next thing you're going to do
is leg curls warm up your hamstrings as
well
and then from there
you know move into your heavier normal
type training and then something to kind
of stretch your quads to end with
one of my go-to's for this is split
squats but generally when you do like
rear leg elevated split squats you're
trying to train the the front leg the
leg that's down so you try to keep most
of your weight shifted forward but to
get a really good stretch in your quads
to end with you want to try to keep a
lot of your weight back so you're you're
keeping
a good amount of the weight on your back
leg and for every rep you're going to go
down you're going to hold that bottom
position of the rear leg elevated split
squat squeeze the glute on the back leg
try to get your hips forward stretch out
your quads and hip flexors really well
and then to initiate the drive up you're
going to drive your front heel through
the floor but you're also going to kick
into the bench um so so it's almost like
you're doing a knee extension with your
back leg as you're doing kind of a
squatting pattern with your front leg uh
and you know
for for the stretchy movement you end on
you also don't want to you don't want
that to be super heavy like you want you
want it to be something where you can
focus more on the stretch than
am i strong enough just to complete the
reps
um
but yeah that
that approach
um
so the the approach i'm generally
describing probably isn't strictly
speaking ideal for strength so uh you
know powerlifters listening to this
might be might be
hearing me and saying like oh no like if
i
did uh a couple sets of 20 to 30 reps
relatively relatively close to failure
for like a pump type triceps exercise
my bench training that comes after like
i might have to take five ten percent
off my training loads
and like
yeah you probably will um that's that's
another you know again for the purpose
of like trying to keep your joints happy
if you can
uh stress all of your target muscles
just as hard um but not have to expose
them to quite as much load
that might be preferable um
so like yeah this is just kind of it's
advice for people who are
trying to stay in the gym trying to
still train hard
but maybe not
necessarily for the for the sole purpose
of
uh maximizing strength performance at
all costs so like it comes with
trade-offs this is more talking about
kind of just like hypertrophy and
quote unquote like general health type
resistance training um
but yeah
i i do
my training looks a lot more like this a
lot of the time these days